you also did me you also did you did me
and and we got a tape you this is this
is Robert doing me
watch this is who's on first how we
doing who's on
first I thought that was you for a
second I thought that was you you got my
that's good
that's that's my friend Doug
Dale what what I don't know this is what
made me this is what bought our first
house
yeah if you have a strong big nose it's
pretty easy to impersonate
Howard and that's that's you doing me oh
there I am and that's me stealing your
ass see well this is how it's done there
you go wow that was look at those
parachute pants love were parachute
pants I never understood that term but
yes I should have had parachute pants to
so that the premise of that sketch this
is like I'm 24 years old and it
was PeeWee Herman and hoe Mandel
performing Who's on First and just
completely wrecking it with props and
and asides and then there was a guy
playing uh Clint East Clint Eastwood who
set it up yeah but that was a sort of we
just sort of stuck that bit and believe
it or not that's that's I auditioned for
SNL with that bit did you and my friend
Doug yes and you got it as a writer I
got it as a writer he was like Lauren
was it's funny that you got it as a
writer because the thing that and I'll
say it about myself I had nothing you
know I had nothing I had no
material and I think you played into
that too cuz I well at the end when I'm
just
going yeah
but
he